- My name is Brendan
Lowry and I'm the creator
and founder of Peopledelphia.
What's exciting about capturing
people with photography
is that there are always
new stories to tell.
I don't think people realize
how much is happening
in Philadelphia and how many
hidden gems there actually are.
There's been a lot that's
changed over the past 10 years
in this city and it's really
exciting time to be here
whether that's in the arts
world, in the restaurant world
there's a lot of things
happening within a bunch
of different industries
that make Philly a really
exciting place to be.
BOK is this old massive school building
which has now been turned
into essentially a massive
makers space, so it's
exciting to see this thing
that was going to be
completely empty now full
of life and something
that's actually impacting
the community, the
economy and really a place
where anyone can go and be inspired.
I'm really excited for the event.
I don't think there's been
anything like this in Philly.
It's super unique.
It's rare that we're able
to have all these artists
in the same room at the same time
in this amazing auditorium that was empty
a couple of years ago.
And now we're using it
to celebrate Philadelphia
artists, celebrate Philadelphia
film makers and really just
show why Philly is such
a unique place.
- It's a really great
building and a great culture.
And honestly this event
represents it really well.
- When I walked into the
building tonight I saw
this amazing blue light
and I said, "What did Chase
put on tonight?"
The level of curiosity that I
have is what really drives me
to try and find these moments
and to capture these moments.
Forcing myself to not always look
at what everyone else is looking at
and to sort of look the
other way and point my camera
in that direction is exciting to me
and it leads me down a
bunch of different paths
that I never thought
that I would maybe take.